STATE RESOURCES.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT," KIND OF AN
AMAZING STORY TO BRING YOU.
NEW RELEASED SURVEILLANCE FROM
THE PARK WHEN FLORIDA SHOOTING
HAS JUST BEEN RELEASED.
IT SHOWS A FORMER DEPUTY SCOTT
PETERSON, THE PERSON IN CHARGE
OF PROTECTING THE BUILDING
ARRIVING OUTSIDE AT THE MOMENT
THAT NICHOLAS CRUZ WAS
CONDUCTING HIS RAMPAGE.
PETERSON THEN STOOD AROUND FOR
SEVERAL MINUTES AS THE SHOOTING
OCCURRED AND DID NOTHING, 17
DIED.
ALSO DOCUMENT SOURCE OBTAINED BY
JUDICIAL WATCH A SHOW HOW
EGREGIOUS THIS FAILURE WAS.
PETERSON'S FAILURE.
TRAINING MANUALS FROM THE
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
ESPECIALLY AND STRUCK OFFICERS
ON THE SCENE TO CONFRONT THE
SHOOTER.
OF COURSE THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN,
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF
JUDICIAL WATCH JOINING US
TONIGHT.
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION WHEN WE
FIRST LEARNED THAT THIS DEPUTY
IN TERMS OF PROTECTING THE
STUDENTS COME OUT THERE WAS SOME
SPECULATION THAT HE WAS TOLD NOT
TO OR THAT THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRED HIM TO WAIT FOR BACKUP.
NOT TRUE.
>> THE MANUAL SAYS HE MAY GO IN
AND TRAINING MATERIALS THAT WE
OBTAINED UNDER THE FLORIDA
SUNSHINE LAW, THE CLASSES AND
MATERIALS SHOW YOU'RE INSTRUCTED
TO TRY TO STOP THE SHOOTERS AS
SOON AS YOU'RE ABLE, WHETHER YOU
ARE ONE DEPUTY, TWO DEPUTIES
SHOWING UP, THREE, OR FOUR.
THE LANGUAGE IS PRETTY STRIKING.
IT SAYS EVERY TIME YOU HEAR A
SHOT, YOU CAN PRESUME ANOTHER
PERSON IS BEING KILLED.
THE INSTRUCTORS ARE TO TRY TO
CONFRONT THE SHOOTER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE ANALYSIS
WAS AFTER COLUMBINE, AS SOON AS
THE SHOOTER IS CONFRONTED BY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ARMED, WILL
THERE BE A POLICE OFFICER,
SCHOOL SECURITY OFFICER, OR A
CIVILIAN WAS CARRYING A
CONCEALED WEAPON, THE SHOOTER
ENGAGES, SHOOTS BACK AND FORTH
OR COMMITS SUICIDE, EITHER WAY,
THE SHOOTING OF INNOCENT PEOPLE
STOPS.
IT'S UPSETTING TO READ THESE
DOCUMENTS KNOWING WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED THAT DAY AND IT SHOWS A
FAILURE BY BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT EITHER TO
PROPERLY TRAIN ITS OFFICERS OR
IN THE CASE OF THE CURRENT
OFFICER WHO HAD TO RESIGN IN
DISGRACE, OBVIOUSLY HE IGNORED
THE TRAINING.
>> Tucker: THIS WASN'T SOME
HIDDEN THING, THIS WAS IN THE
TRAINING MANUAL.
THE SHARE OF ISRAEL WENT TO THE
CNN GUN-CONTROL RALLY AND SET ON
THE STAGE AND BLAMED ARMED
CITIZENS, BLAMED THE MIDDLE OF
THE COUNTRY BASICALLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND NEVER MENTIONED THE
FAILURES OF HIS DEPUTY, BUT HE
MUST'VE KNOWN THAT THIS WAS
PROTOCOL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
OTHER DEPUTIES ARRIVED AND THEY
DIDN'T GO INTO THE BUILDING AS
QUICKLY AS THEY SHOULD HAVE
EITHER.
THEY TALK ABOUT IF YOU HAVE FOUR
DEPUTIES GO IN, YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO FORM UP IN A QUAD, THEY CALL
IT, GO IN AND CONFRONT THE
SHOOTER.
>> Tucker: I THINK THERE WERE
FOUR DEPUTIES OUTSIDE ARMED
DURING THE SHOOTING.
>> PETERSON WAS THERE, THREE
OTHERS SHOWED UP AND IT TOOK
THEM A BIT TO ENTER THE
BUILDING.
PETERSON COULD HAVE GONE IN BY
HIMSELF, ANOTHER DEPUTY ARRIVES,
THEY COULD HAVE GONE IN
TOGETHER, THEY RECOMMEND IF YOU
GO IN TOGETHER, THERE IS A
TECHNIQUE FOR APPROACHING THE
SHOOTER IF YOU'RE JUST A TWO-MAN
WHAT'S FRUSTRATING ABOUT THIS,
YOU SEE THIS MATERIAL AND YOU'RE
RECOGNIZING WITH THE FAILURE WAS
THAT LED TO THIS.
WE SUFFERED THROUGH THESE
RIDICULOUS DEMONSTRATIONS
YESTERDAY, NOT RIDICULOUS.
KIDS ARE FEARED FOR THE SAFETY
AND CAME OUT WITH WHAT THEY
THOUGHT, BUT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH WITH THE SITUATION AND
PARKLAND WAS WHICH WAS THE
FAILURE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
FOLLOW THEIR OWN PROTOCOLS TO
PROTECTING CIVILIANS.
ON TOP OF THAT, WE NOW KNOW
ABOUT THE FBI FAILING TO FOLLOW
UP.
>> Tucker: THE AUTHORITIES
FAILED TO PROTECT US, THEY LIED
ABOUT IT AND BLAMED US.
>> AND NOW THE TALK IS, WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE AWAY GUNS.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PROTECTING KIDS IN SCHOOLS.
>> Tucker: RATHER THAN ACCEPT
BLAME, THEY TURN AROUND.
>> FRANKLY, A VIEWER SHOULD GO
LOOK AT THESE DOCUMENTS.
WHEN THEY SEE WITH THE TRAINING
WAS, THEY'LL SEE'S EXTREMELY